In order to have to go out and get out, it's actually a gourmet meal Yes, but
when I open it, I shoot it without stinging.
I hope you can feel the change of emotions a little bit.
Don't think like
that.  I am
doing uh,
which direction surpasses 4 points Now, meeting people really means a lot because I always think of
you  What do you like the most, and basically,
a little more of the prizes I want to
give you.
Oops so a and suggestion Oh why twice to once is
not an easy topic Stand up for a few hours and the time is about 3 hours
5 I think something is different And there is no test Mom era Especially express
ubiquitous 600 to oppose Ike Check or leave of Jiwoo
universe ver
Cosmo Branch MV Suju Botox Bae Nuri Wondae
Uh
Ah Yeh Talk Uh I don't know if this is possible or not.
He did his eyebrows like he did.
Yes there is um 1
just like this I  He said he wished he would be happy for a long time, he said it would be so.
The part that I do is that I am not interested in going on this trip, so I wake up and
now people around me are always asking me if I should
be in a relationship.  Because I think about it,
I'm just having a relationship of my own thanks to the sick people and the fans
.
The sea was free
This song is now a song that I originally loved very much Gore It's already a song that I worked on more than before this album. I was
looking for a suitable burger and came to know T-ara.
I don't think I really have the idea that I want to blow up the semester c and iol master to love on top of it in some mix. As of
right now, somehow, I'm feeling the happiest in letting ham people hear our voices,
and, well, by necessity, this  Gogo Taepyeongsa Oh,
if you wish there was a mokkuri like this
, you seem to be looking for food in the industry in the mountain of cows.
9 seems to be the most important thing, in other words, in
the case of K-pop, communication with fans is really important, and some kind of
emotional exchange with fans is important.
I think it would be nice to think a lot about communication
h14  Tenant pun-out 10 servers, why 8 houses, I know the south that will be used young.
Then, just like now, I think I can get it with the silver people, and I got a
little
better.
Once I saw the beginner's quest, I saw it. Now, cucumber and apple course
black sand ambiguous - I had to drink it.